hello Facebook or whoever you are I'm
trying to copeland we're in the CBS this
morning Toyota greenroom with the New
Yorkers Pulitzer Prize winning culture
critic Emily Nussbaum she's a new book
out it's called I'd like to watch here's
a copy right here
it's arguing my way through the TV
revolution Emily thanks for being here
thanks for having me it's a little bit
weird to be talking to a TV guy on the
internet about television that you wrote
about it's like we're kind of
ricocheting off various mediums here
yeah here we are what is the argument at
the center of the book well essentially
it's a it's a collection of my writing
about television over the last 20 years
with a bunch of new stuff but the
argument in it that they all the pieces
come together to make is about
celebrating television as television and
detaching it from constant comparisons
to books and movies and it's really a
book about expanding the kind of TV that
we take seriously and celebrating all of
it and that means soap operas reality
shows sort of dropping the the status
anxiety that causes people to call
things guilty pleasures I'm also against
guilty pleasures I think it's a pleasure
it's a pleasure
no guilt needed so do you think if TV
was invented before the book and the
printing press we would laud television
and deride the book well I'm trying to
walk through the situation in which TV
was invented before I mean after all
novels essentially like I mean novels
were treated as a kind of television
like derided art form when they first
came out partially because they were
episodic they came out in individual
chapters that were published and once
they were combined together in two books
they gained more status but honestly at
the time novels were first invented they
had a lot of the bad reputation TV does
now that's something that women read and
distracted them from their homes and
that were kind of Opie attic and sexual
and so all new things are derided for a
period of time and then critics like
yourself come along and they lift it up
well the main thing about the TV being
compared to books and movies is that
yeah those books and movies are art
forms that people think of as art and so
they have a form of criticism that's
directed toward them aesthetically and
so when TV started getting better
one of the things that people would do
is they would look at a show like a
wonderful show like The Sopranos and
they'd say this shows great it's not
like TV because for decades people
talked about television itself as this
terrible gross addictive harmful thing
it was scooping on our brains I mean
there was a famous book an 80s amusing
ourselves to death it's gonna be there
it was gonna be the ruination and not
only of your individual family or your
life but the country yes definitely and
it certainly wasn't seen as any kind of
art form at best it was seen as
something that could spread good
messages at worst to destroy your brain
so basically it was the internet right
now everything yep you got into this
line of work because of Buffy the
Vampire Slayer walk me through this yeah
okay so I was in graduate school for
Literature for Victorian literature and
I was hanging out in the West Village
taking a break from reading 900 page
novels and I had a small TV set this was
in 1997 so it was back in the Dark Ages
no I was watching the TV and I turned on
the show Buffy which I'd heard some good
things about and honestly it was this
massive insane conversion experience I
don't feel quite that way anymore but I
fell in love with the show at the time
and I really did become a fan I'm not
saying that I immediately dropped out of
graduate school and became a television
critic it took a few more years but it
created a feeling of me of an evangelism
feeling of wanting to talk to people
about the show and it was out at the
same time as The Sopranos was out which
is another show that I loved very much
but I was very frustrated by the very
different critical reactions to do the
two shows and in the book I talked about
how this was sort of the base coat on
the passionate argument that I kept
making for years that basically said
there has to be a language to celebrate
both of these kinds of shows and the
many kinds of shows because for a long
time
I think to deal with people shame and
anxiety about TV the only kind of TV
that they were capable of praising was
TV that they could say was not TV like
and Buffy the Vampire Slayer very TV
like you don't sound like a TV critic
you sound like a TV cheerleader at the
moment that is true in the case of this
particular show but I have to
see being a fan of something is
different than being a critic obviously
I think anybody who reads this book will
see that I also write critical reviews
but there is a way in which I did start
writing about television because I felt
like I loved the medium even if I didn't
love individual shows and honestly when
I was younger I didn't want to be a
critic because I was an artsy hippie and
it felt mean to criticize things and in
a lot of ways I really avoided writing
criticism until I found television where
it felt like if I criticized an
individual show it was actually a way of
praising television because it was a way
of holding it to high standards and
saying it could be great because for
years a lot of TV criticism was
essentially condescending you know if a
TV show did anything ambitious it would
sort of get a pat on the head
yeah but I feel like that's changed and
not just for me there's a huge range of
passionate writing online and off about
TV so it's a wonderful thing to get paid
twice for a single piece of writing and
so some of the pieces in here have
already been published others have not
how did you select what goes into the
book out of the many things you've
written over the last decade well it
does have new material in the book as
well but new material people don't worry
if you've been reading The New Yorker
you know this is not just a collection
and and their stuff also from my work at
New York magazine
earlier this isn't a collection of the
shows I like the best it's not a top ten
list it's a collection of pieces that
are designed to make the argument that
I'm talking about the Buffy Sopranos
argument but also the argument about
having the language to talk about what
TV is that TV is a in episodic art form
a collaborative art form about TVs
relationship with the audience and how
that's changed TV and the pieces that I
selected are meant to kind of link
together to form that argument and also
there is a memoir like quality to
criticism so when I look at the
inherently I mean it's my opinion it's
not a mathematical judgment of the shows
and there's a I think there's a personal
edge to a lot of criticism I mean
criticism is a theatrical expression of
your voice and when I look at the pieces
a lot of them show me struggling with
certain ideas pushing up against
the limits of my own understanding
changing my mind and I think that's part
of the book as well I think it's
wonderful that you say that criticism is
a theatrical presentation because what
we do out there is sometimes derided as
as theatre as though people who are
writing are not adopting a tone and a
point of view and and and having
personality I mean tone on the page is
no different than a smile into the
camera I think that's true thank you
very much
[Laughter]
there is one of the new essays is about
the me2 moment and you think through
many issues one of which is one that's
on the minds of a lot of people which is
what do I do is something I love where I
now know that the creator or the actor
is maybe not a great person
well this essay which is a mixture of a
personal essay and a critical analysis
it's it's it's a complicated piece and
this piece exists literally because my
book leave happened in the fall of 2017
and the Harvey Weinstein piece came down
and the me2 movement began and I
abandoned plans to write several other
essays and instead wrote this big essay
wrestling with this issue and as a
critic it's a different thing for me
than I think for other people because
the idea of separating the artist from
the art when you're just a consumer or a
fan is one thing but part of what I
struggle with in that piece is what's my
relationship with these men's work and
you know I go back decades thinking
about like my early love of Woody Allen
my relationship with artists like Bill
Cosby Roman Polanski louis c.k and the
the piece is is essentially my version
of what I think a lot of women and men
actually have gone through in the last
few years which is what a friend of mine
called the audit where you sort of look
back on your life and you think about
where did my values come from what are
my reactions to these experiences so but
yeah part of it is about this specific
ethical question about what do I do with
this work now like how do I regard it
critically how do I regard it
emotionally and I try to take the
different the different people and
different ways like I talked about The
Cosby Show and its role on TV there is
no it's a very personal decision how one
relates to those were
and everybody will come to their own
negotiation with themselves on their own
conclusion and I'm sure it's different
for different people and different
products but what are the guidelines
that you have for yourself for myself
yeah I'm still working that out I mean
this is the thing is you can write an
essay and not actually come to clear
conclusions and yeah exactly I mean this
is this is a wrestling act and it's me
struggling with this I mean at the end I
III do think that by nature I'm not a
cancel delete person I understand the
arguments for essentially erasing
somebody's work but they don't come
naturally to me and as a critic I feel
like it's my obligation to actually
wrestle with the work and with the works
relationship to the person's life and
that's what I actually try to do in the
essay is take some of these things that
I love including you know masterpieces
like Rosemary's Baby and think about the
relationship between that and Polanski
thinking about The Cosby Show which was
essentially a an incredibly important
part of TV that I don't think can be
erased or deleted but that I have to
acknowledge its existence was the way
Bill Cosby gained access to his victims
so yeah that's what the piece is about I
mean there's a related question which is
becoming more relevant as streaming
services put older shows online and
introduce them to a whole new audience
what do you do with dated references to
dated language to dated points of view
how do you how do you consume it how do
you explain it to the next generation or
maybe watching with you this comes up
all the time and actually I love that
all this old TV is available that was
never true before like you can't talk
about TV without talking about
technology and I always talk about how
the ways TV changed can't be
distinguished from the development of
DVRs and the fact that you could pause
or rewind it and discuss it online and
streaming is this whole thing but the
sudden influx of an archival TV is
fascinating to me because I used to be
constantly Hawking people and saying you
have to watch shows from the 70s to
understand what sitcoms are and you know
I was like this foggy insisting that
people educate themselves about TV but
now that's actually possible at a
certain point it's so interesting to me
all the younger people suddenly started
watching friends
criticizing friends and to watch and
criticize friends from the perspective
of today is extremely different from
watching it when you were the age of the
characters and it was on and I mean I
basically think people do have to take
art within the context in which it was
made that's the more fruitful way to
talk about it not to just it's not my
favorite thing when people just had
published like a list of things that are
problematic about a show I think there
are richer ways to engage with it but
look I mean it's true you look at older
art and you sometimes have a shocked
reaction to the language they use but it
was fascinated they just should had
Norman Lear's one of my favorites CBS
guy and it was just that crazy live
thing that was done on CBS where they
did it on ABC TV but with our dweller
okay sorry but it was so strange was
like a live presentation of to Norman
Lear shows I think he was all in the
family episode and good times episode
and people watching it were so shocked
by just the the language of talking
about race and identity and the thing
which was native to the 70s yeah I loved
it and I was also kind of excited just
to see a live TV show I don't know it
was a weird experiment but we do it live
two hours every morning right there they
were gonna show but the humor favorite
right now actually wasn't by the way it
was in good times it was um I'm sorry
suddenly I'm blanking The Jeffersons
it was the Jeopardy Christmas yeah you
have a favorite right now on TV I'm
traditional TV not streaming it's all
one big TV thing like a network yeah you
have a favorite well okay no we I don't
want to force it I don't want there's no
there's no good way the conversation you
go I'm very interested in network
television I have a lot of nostalgia for
a lot of the traditional model of
production and things coming out week by
week but it's true I can't separate in
my head like I'll tell you because I was
gonna name an HBO show so oh that's fine
name an HBO show we name-- whatever
Spooky's loads of Spooky's fred armisen
'he's new show okay so good so funny
alright weird never really great it was
a great surprise you know your TV critic
you get a lot of screeners and then
there's this native crankiness to all TV
critics right now because there's so
much TV so it's wonderful when you watch
something and then you're pleasantly
surprised and this is a great show like
that so given that you're constantly
watching things for work and you I know
your parent as well do you have your
your eighth grade son or daughter son
you have one son two two kids are they
like watching TV all the time we're
streaming all the time and every time
you try to get them off of it they're
they're like learned it from you mom the
TV today this is your brain on TV no i
watch i watch some shows with them i
mean like a lot of kids their age
they're actually more into other kinds
of things that I'm fascinated by the
YouTube videos they watch and just
really like the watch youtubers that are
like a guy who reads from funny reddit
threads which is a really fascinating
strange idea of what you would watch but
I watched their stuff that's amazing
with me there's a few shows I mean we're
into comedies and so we watched the
office 30 rock perks and wreck the good
place we're watching Kim's convenience
right now which is this great Canadian
show we watch the middle so and our big
show is Jane the Virgin so we just we
have shows that the boys and I watch
together but that that's basically it I
mean TV's more my thing in my house all
right
I do take away from that that the sitcom
is not dead no I'm lives I'm look what
can I say comedies on television right
now especially a network better than
dramas if you've been watching too much
TV and you want something to read Emily
Nussbaum I like to watch very good being
here thank you five days get out there
whoever you are